[Musica]
eccoci mi hanno suggerito calorosamente
di cominciare con la domanda perché le
domande creano quel bel feeling con il
pubblico li fanno entrare nell'argomento
vi fanno riflettere quindi ho deciso di
obbedire tranquillamente a questo grande
consiglio la mia domanda è la seguente
che cos'è il tempo ma proprio così in
generale non stiamo qua a pensare al
timer del forno a che ore sono alla data
di scadenza dello yogurt al lampone
pensiamo invece al tempo come un
concetto astratto un po in generale come
se lo dovessimo spiegare a un ipotetico
entità che non ha assolutamente idea di
come funzioni o della sua esistenza
ecco ci renderemo conto in questo questa
vastissima parentesi che vi ho dato per
rifletterci ci renderemo conto che è un
concetto un pochino più complicato di
quello che potrebbe sembrare da dove
viene quanto dura dove doveva di cosa è
fatto come funziona
stephen hawking quando ha deciso di
approcciarsi al tema del tempo si è reso
conto ben presto che il modo più
funzionale per venirne a capo era
scriverci su un libro di ben 256 pagine
e stiamo parlando di stephen hawking
quindi ovvio le sue intenzioni erano un
pochino più ambiziose lui voleva sia
raccontarsi e raccontarci da dove viene
il tempo quali sono le sue origini ma
voleva anche costruire una teoria
dell'universo che riuscisse a spiegarci
un po da dove era arrivato
noi siamo molto meno ambiziosi di così
un po perché nostro malgrado non siamo
brillanti quanto stephen hawking ma
anche perché per nostra fortuna i
problemi che ci troviamo a dover
risolvere sono di natura decisamente
molto più contingente
e quindi l'essere umano di solito è
capace di gloriosissimi lanci di
astrazione ma anche fatto del senso
pratico direi una potentissima arma
evolutiva ecco perché di base noi
tendiamo a spiegarci il tempo in base a
come lo impegniamo come lo impieghiamo
tendiamo a raccontarcelo in base a
quello che ci è capitato ci capita
oppure ci capiterà anche in questa sua
versione un po edulcorata semplificata e
sintetizzate in tempo però continua a
prestare dei dei problemi a darci dei
problemi ci sembra un po complicato da
gestire un po impervio un po un po
strano e perché il tempo per le persone
inevitabilmente non è mai un concetto
neutro ci finiscono dentro le azioni che
compiamo quindi a una sequenza di azioni
ma è anche una sorta di vettore emotivo
più o meno lungo ci finiscono dentro le
cose che facciamo ma anche come ci
sentiamo mentre le facciamo e poi visto
che abbiamo la piena libertà di farci
del male fino in fondo nel tempo vanno a
finire anche i nostri sentimenti nei
confronti del tempo io per esempio ho 33
anni e ho l'impressione di aver
combattuto con il tempo più o meno da
quando ne ho memoria non è colpa del
tempo però per quanto i miei sentimenti
possono risultare un po tetri e un po
contraddittorie ti viene voglia di dare
colpa il tempo ma non è non è un
problema suo il tempo prevalentemente
per continuare a scorrere
sicuramente non ha bisogno delle nostre
lezioni di yoga del martedì delle nostre
8 ore in ufficio delle nostre aziende
alte una spanna piene zeppe di adorabili
foglietti pieni di appunti e nemmeno dei
save the date dei matrimoni il tempo
esiste indipendentemente da quello che
ci possiamo fare da quello che possiamo
pensare di lui è più una questione di
contesto e delle sovrastrutture della
civiltà che abitiamo perché non mi
sembra che
ci troviamo in un contesto
particolarmente paziente o poco
competitivo
anzi il tempo e il come lo usiamo sembra
qualificarci quello che ci facciamo
diventa molto spesso sinonimo del valore
assoluto della nostra vita e per questo
motivo che molto spesso siamo
terrorizzati dalla prospettiva di
perdere tempo oppure ci fa paura la
staticità rimanere bloccati in una
situazione che magari non ci sembra
particolarmente auspicabile soprattutto
quando ci giriamo e vediamo che tutto il
resto continua a muoversi senza di noi
noi siamo siamo condizionati
collettivamente a sentirci molto più
bravi e molto più speciali in base a
quante cose facciamo a quante cose
vediamo leggiamo viviamo a quante cose
siamo in estrema sintesi e pensiamo
anche sempre di che quello che importa
davvero è essere il più possibile attivi
indaffarati ed efficienti
e come se vole riempiendo il più
possibile del nostro tempo volessimo
anche cancellare gli spazi vuoti dentro
di noi la durata della vita è il nostro
orizzonte e per quanto può essere
auspicabile augurarsi di vivere una vita
piena felice interessante e ricca in
questo nostro inanellare continuamente
azioni e impegni in realtà si nasconde
anche la paura di vivere poco se così la
possiamo chiamare è come se l'inazione c
ci togliesse dei pezzi ci togliesse
proprio dei pezzi di vita ma la vita
proprio come il tempo non è misurabile
in termini neutrali parentesi
autobiografica così ci riprendiamo poco
poco dopo aver amaramente compiuto 30
anni che mi rendo conto non sia uno
scoglio particolarmente terrificante per
molti ma io onestamente nei miei 20 mi
ci trovavo molto bene ci sarei rimasta
volendo ancora un po poco dopo aver
compiuto 30 anni mi sono resa conto di
non riuscire a ricordare con una
particolare nitidezza un momento della
mia vita in cui avevo effettivamente
avuto del tempo è una sensazione
abbastanza brutta immagino comune comune
a molti in quel nostro dirci
continuamente che non abbiamo tempo
spesso in tante volte al giorno e in
diversi ambiti della nostra vita e di
quello che facciamo in realtà stiamo
costruendo una specie di classificazione
del tempo stiamo creando una gerarchia
del tempo che ha irrimediabilmente a che
fare con l'identità
io per esempio sono sempre stata una
bambina molto molto impegnata ma proprio
a livello di cose che dovevo fare
tennis sci musica pianoforte un sacco di
cose indipendentemente da quello che mi
veniva già richiesto per la scuola però
sono anche cresciuta sentendomi
continuamente dire che io non mi
impegnavo abbastanza che io non ero
abbastanza tenace che che non mi
sbattevo a sufficienza proprio per
essere belli gracci in realtà mi sono
resa conto molto dopo pensandoci io sono
una delle persone più testardi e
caparbie che mi sia mai capitato di
incontrare peccato però che che tutti
questi miei sforzi non risultassero
evidenti nelle cose che mi ritrovavo a
dover fare un giorno dopo giorno
quotidianamente
perché io tutto il mio impegno lo
riversava nel creare altro tempo tempo
che vi desse la possibilità di scegliere
di capire che cos'era di capire quali
erano le strade che dovevo seguire per
davvero trovare uno scopo o un posto nel
mondo
nonostante questo però non ho mai smesso
di fare di produrre e di studiare tutto
quello che ci si aspettava da me
sicuramente è una faccenda di dinamiche
familiari di relazioni e anche a che
fare un sacco con il crescere ci
mancherebbe ma ha soprattutto a che
vedere con le aspettative un po quelle
che ci creiamo da soli e un po quelle
che ci buttano addosso agli altri o che
ci sembra che gli altri ci stiano
buttando addosso e queste aspettative
sono comuni a tutti noi in realtà tutti
questi è così che si vive è così che le
cose dovrebbero andare e questo è
l'ordine corretto in cui dovremo fare
determinate cose sono degli scogli con
cui ci confrontiamo tutti il suono degli
scogli che hanno anche il potere di
scavare un solco molto profondo nel
nostro tempo efficace metafora se
immaginiamo il tempo che abbiamo
complessivamente a disposizione come se
fosse il disco fisso di un computer
tutte queste azioni quel tempo lì che è
composto delle cose che dobbiamo
obbligatoriamente fare per rallegrare
tutti e per dimostrare di essere dei
membri funzionanti e produttivi di
questo mondo
ecco quel tempo li occupa uno spazio
molto cospicuo io pertanto per tanto
tempo
quante volte potremo mai impasti ciarci
con questa con questa parola molto a
lungo sono mi sono resa conto di
di essermi definita sempre e quasi solo
per differenza
questa cosa non fa per me questo non mi
piace
questo non è tanto adatto in questo non
sono brava
questo magari no ecco tutte queste cose
però continuavano a far parte del mio
orizzonte ma non solo del mio presente
potenzialmente anche del mio futuro ma
anche all'infinito per quello che ne
potevo sapere e non solo tutte queste
cose diventavano sempre più ingombranti
all'interno del mio disco fisso ma
diventavano anche molto più onerose da
gestire perché esistere alla fine in uno
spazio che diventa così piccolo diventa
anche molto più oneroso quando noi
diciamo che non abbiamo tempo forse non
solo nascondiamo un po quella paura di
perdere dei pezzi o di cose che potremmo
essere
stiamo anche dicendo forse che si è
difficile infilare la tredicesima col
della giornata in pausa pranzo perché è
oggettivamente complicato però stiamo
anche dicendo forse che non abbiamo più
le energie per combattere per quel
pezzettino di tempo che dovrebbe essere
la nostra vera casa è il nostro vero
rifugio
ora non voglio spezzare una lancia a
favore di quelli che ci consigliano a
ogni piè sospinto di mollare tutto e
aprire un bar sulla spiaggia o ancora
meglio quelli che ci suggeriscono di
mollare tutto ancora una volta e di
girare il mondo in barca a vela con il
nostro gatto
no non io non c'ho mai molto creduto e
soprattutto poi dopo un po salta sempre
fuori che queste persone sono veramente
molto ricche di famiglia e quindi non
grazie no mi rendo anche conto che su un
palco dove si parla di futuro forse
dovrei anche essere un pochino più
incoraggiante di così però non ho
soluzioni mirabolanti non ho neanche dei
cilindri magici da cui tirare fuori
nelle ore libere invece che dei conigli
bianchi offesissimo o solo una piccola
considerazione da da condividere
mi sono accorta che le cose vanno meglio
anche ma anche solo un pochino meglio
quando riusciamo a dare un po più di
equilibrio alle varie porzioni del
nostro disco fisso a quando ci fermiamo
a riflettere a quando ci accorgiamo che
non stiamo mettendo in pratica quasi
nulla di tutto quello che abbiamo
imparato mentre ci cercavamo a quando
aggiustiamo la rotta e magari o anche ci
impantaniamo volontariamente perché in
quel momento lì impantanarci è la
soluzione più più adatta è quello di cui
abbiamo bisogno è quel ci sono tante
circostanze spesso contingenti che ci
impediscono di avvicinarci davvero alla
nostra idea di felicità molto spesso non
ci arriviamo vicino neanche proprio con
il binocolo neanche lontanamente
ma il punto non sta tanto lì il punto
sta più che altro nell'imparare a
misurarci in una maniera diversa
anzi nel renderci conto che la misura
siamo noi e possiamo essere solamente
noi e che quel famoso come ci sentiamo
nei confronti del tempo
in realtà è la chiave che dovrebbe
aiutarci a individuare quegli ingranaggi
che si sono inceppati o anche quelli che
magari girano a vuoto quelli che fanno
muovere una macchina di cui siamo solo
dei passeggeri e non avremo mai la
possibilità di guidare ora far entrare
un immaginaria scatola di cioccolatini
da cui estrarre una definizione di
futuro perché il futuro se ci pensiamo
molto terra terra è cioè tutte quelle
cose che non ci sono ancora capitate per
arrivarci però abbiamo bisogno di
partire ovviamente dal presente ed è
quella parte di noi del nostro disco
fisso che potremmo davvero etichettare
con noi che dovrebbe avere la
possibilità di indicarci la strada
il tempo c'è una grandezza inevitabile
non possiamo sempre controllarle magari
neanche la capiamo e nel nostro percorso
ci fa tante cose
il tempo ci può trascinare anche
violentemente ci può guidare ci può ci
può spiegare delle cose che magari
subito non avevamo compreso veramente in
un viaggio così così lungo ci auguriamo
in un viaggio così complesso e così
importante ci sono due fattori che
secondo me sono da tenere in
considerazione
uno è la direzione e l'altro è
sicuramente la compagnia se la direzione
si può aggiustare pian piano come
abbiamo visto la cosa di cui dobbiamo
davvero prenderci cura e proprio la
compagnia e la compagnia più rilevante
tra tutte è quella che noi facciamo a
noi stessi e se dobbiamo pensare anche
in un'ottica di futuro a noi stessi
dobbiamo fare un grande regalo è un
regalo che dovrebbe riuscire a renderci
un pochino meno trafelati a farci
sentire un pochino meno inadeguati
sempre di corsa sempre incapace di
gestire quello che ci sta succedendo e
quindi forse anche un pochino più liberi
e un po più felici che questo regalo
secondo me è un buon margine di manovra
perché sappiamo bene che lo spazio sul
nostro disco fisso così come il nostro
tempo non è infinito però un po di
spazio ce l'abbiamo e vale la pena
provare a riprenderselo anche solo un
pezzettino alla volta una briciolina
alla volta
l'ideale sarebbe anche farlo mentre
proviamo davvero a immaginarci qualcosa
di meglio per il nostro futuro
[Musica]